If you had many conversations
you know already that we don't believe
in God.
If you had more conversations with more
people
you would know. I've been here for the
last I've been here since 2000 I've been
I've been coming since 2005 but I've
been I've been in discussion from
2007-8, okay? And I know Christians very
very well.
I don't know if you except No, there is
other ones that don't believe Jesus to
be God. But there's a lot of Christians
do believe Jesus to be God.
So you don't believe Jesus to be God. Me
me me honestly
you Muslim I admire you. Thank you. Very
uh Thank you.
very pow- powerful speaker.
Very articulate, very respectful and I
see your
your conversation very I call it very
honest and very
Try my best.
I'm Sunni alhamdulillah, yes. Try my
best, you know.
But what we say to you brother, there's
no salvation and success in this life
except by following the prophet Muhammad
If Jesus was alive he would command you
if he was here he would command you to
follow Muhammad alaihi salatu was salam.
Like we believe if when Jesus was here
on the earth teaching, if Moses was
alive he would tell the to Jewish people
follow Jesus cuz all of them came with
the same message. Me me me myself I have
an
encounter with Jesus myself in 2009.
I had a
I had an issue mental issue. Okay.
And I was really ill I prayed
and he came I heard his voice saying How
do you know that that was his voice?
Save my son now.
But how do you know that he was that was
his voice? Maybe that was Satan playing
with your mind.
>> No no because I feel calm. Yes, I know
that.
>> Feel calm, no more fear. No problem. And
the prophet Muhammad's disciple his name
Ibn Mas'ud
so he saw
uh someone having what do you call it in
English
uh what was it again? Something he put
in chest or hung it over his neck like a
chain. Okay? Necklace. And he says since
I've been having it, I have no mental
issues or I have no harm from the Satan.
He said because Satan wants to put this
one, when he did, he left you cuz he put
you in a bigger trouble. So when the
Satan [snorts] made you believe that
Jesus and encounter with Jesus, he's
going to leave you alone. Cuz remember
Sorry to interrupt. Sorry. Remember, we
have the text and we have our personal
experience. If our personal experience
goes against the text, what are we going
to do?
You know You know You know You know the
story from your prophet when he met the
Jibril
in the grave. In In the grave? Yeah, we
we are No, no, sorry. In the cave. Okay,
in the cave.
Don't worry. I'm I'm from Holland, so my
So
So that you can see that
what happened then when the when the
angel come to him in a way to fear him
to struggle him. Yes. To breathe.
I found it a bit
a bit disturbing because
if he if uh
if he's a
if if if he's an
if he's an angel
angels don't do that. Angels don't come
in a in a aggressive way like this. Who
said that? In the Bible there's there's
a situation when the when the angel came
in aggressive way. No.
What was his name?
Jeremiah No, Jeremiah.
What was it?
>> Zechariah. No, Daniel. What Daniel?
Yeah, but he
he The different is How is it different
now? The different is the way he
represent himself. Yeah. He say his
name. Yeah.
>> fear not. No, no, but it's same thing.
Same thing.
When When So, from the Arab culture, to
repeat something three times. And he was
squeezing him to get him prepared what
he's going to hear. Okay?
Now Now, watch this. He told him He
said, "Oh, Oh
you are the messenger of Allah, and I am
Jibril, the angel of Allah.
I don't think I don't I don't I don't I
don't
I don't know which which source it come
because That's in Bukhari. Because he
going Bukhari but not in the because
>> Same story that you mentioned is in
Bukhari as well.
Did he not go to his wife first?
Yeah, but there's not yes to Aisha. So
to
to Khadija, yes. And then Warqa said go
with him.
>> Warqa Yes, but angel himself told him as
well.
Yes, angel told him. He said, "Oh
Muhammad,
the point here, look,
you cannot dictate why why why why.
Okay, you know why? Cuz same thing can
apply to to you. Yeah. Okay? Why God had
to wait for thousands of years before
sending his son to die for our sins? I
know. We don't Why?
Because God wants to us
to make his prophecy come out.
To change God has work to do in
prophets. Yeah, which is? When he is
made by when he make the line, he needs
to carry at his time.
Not our time. Huh? God God doesn't work
logic. God working in Yeah, same thing.
You are using logic. God doesn't work
logic. There's same thing apply to you
by asking why.
I'm saying that certain things is is a
side point. The point here is now
Prophet Muhammad
when he received the revelation, was he
hide it or he came out openly to
challenge the people that what he has is
from God? He came out openly and he told
them this is the work I'm receiving from
God and he told them many things that
shows he was so confident what he has is
from God. And what is very interesting,
he told Allah told him in the Quran that
you will overpower other nations. So if
Prophet Muhammad was a liar,
it's impossible for God all the time aid
a liar over his beloved ones. Cuz if the
Christian and the Jewish people are the
beloved ones, Allah aid his Prophet
Muhammad, then his disciples, then his
nations and he's still aiding the
Muslims, you know? So sorry sorry. So
it's illogical irrational for Allah to
aid a liar cuz Allah sometimes allows a
liar Yeah. to have some victory, but
eventually will expose him. But
historically, Allah been aiding his
prophet Muhammad all the time. Rather,
there's a verse in the Quran, Allah said
to prophet Muhammad, "You will never
die, and you will never be killed until
you
until Islam Islam will be established."
The meaning of the verse, yes?
Now, when Allah when Allah revealed this
verse to prophet Muhammad, prophet
Muhammad was not
was not hiding in his house and saying
it. He was involved in a war in a places
where it's more likely to be KILLED OR
TO DIE, BUT ALLAH PROMISED HIM THAT YOU
WILL NEVER DIE. You will never be killed
until you
Islam will be established. According to
the Bible, how do you know true prophet?
If he's if he prophesized something in
the future and it comes to pass, it's a
true prophet. That's exactly what
happened. I don't I don't I don't think
that there's it's true what you say
because
Muhammad
when the
when Muhammad died sallallahu alayhi
wasallam Islam just start to growing
through your scholars. No, after the
prophet died and the Arab world was
under him. Your scholars keep correcting
him. Correcting now, no?
Where? Where did you get that from?
No, I I if I hear if I heard if I heard
the uh the Hadith
uh Tafsir, they keep correcting things.
What correcting? There's no correcting.
Yeah. Where? Where did you get that
from? Because
>> making it up. Look at Look when Jesus is
different. Jesus when he spoke to the 12
disciples, he put all his uh 3 years in
the disciples.
He bring them everywhere, you know? He
explain them. No, he didn't. Jesus Jesus
couldn't explain himself, Jesus.
>> He explain
>> No, Jesus couldn't explain himself.
>> Brother, you guys believe that he's
perfect. No, I don't believe he's
perfect. No. Only Allah is perfect.
I believe he was I believe Jesus is
infallible. Like I know that Jesus,
prophet Muhammad, all the prophets and
messengers are infallible
in conveying the message. They don't
fall into sins, major sins. But
according to the Bible,
even Hitler can be a prophet of God.
Yes, okay. Who is worse? David is a
prophet.
Yes. No, no, no, he's a He's a prophet,
yeah.
>> And a king and a king. But he's a
prophet as well. David, he killed many
people. David,
David he was a liar. David So, if if
liar, murderer, cheater can be a
prophet, Hitler can be prophet, too.
YEAH, YEAH.
SO,
ONE THING I WANT TO SAY, THEREFORE
NO, but
but Jesus choose him.
Jesus choose him to be a prophet.
Jesus, according to your belief, of
course, Jesus or God, are you are you
Are you more wiser than God?
Not.
Would you choose a liar, murderer,
deceiver, cheater as your ambassador?
Now, I'm asking you before you I'm
talking about Christ now.
If you know someone is a liar, deceiver,
murderer, cheater, would you choose him
as your ambassador?
Ambassador of To convey your message,
would you choose him?
No. No. So, how God is choosing I don't
believe, by the way. I believe David
never commit any crimes. It's a lie
against our beloved prophet, David. I
don't believe that. But I'm saying the
Christians and the Jewish people have no
legs to stand on to criticize Prophet
Muhammad Alaihi Salatu Was Salam because
according to the Bible
he had to be like free from that. He was
a deceiver, he was a cheater, he was a
murderer, but yet he's a prophet of God.
No, no, because
David King David King David wasn't a He
was anointed by Samuel first.
But he was a prophet. He's a prophet.
And he was brave as a young man. He was
a shepherd, a shepherd I know, but I'm
saying he was a prophet. He's a
Huh? He was a prophet as well. But he
was more than that. You looking only on
the on the Brother, I respect you, but
you missed the point. The point here is
Brother, if a prophet can be a liar and
deceiver, you should not reject anyone
to be a prophet.
Are you having me he's going to do more?
No, no, no. No, you you know you if you
read the Bible you know he he wrote
wrote the Psalms, you know? He bring the
kingdom.
>> Yeah, but that's a side point. The point
here is
you have nothing to reject Prophet
Muhammad Alaihi Wasallam. You have no
leg. You have nothing to reject Prophet
Muhammad Alaihi Wasallam. Prophet
Muhammad Alaihi Wasallam, he was known
to be trustworthy and truthful and
honest. Prophet Muhammad Alaihi Wasallam
I I
okay. Tell me what what what what
Prophet what
what Prophet Muhammad lied about. Tell
me. I'll tell you why. Go on. Jesus tell
also about the heart like the heart of
if you desire
to be famous, to have money, to have
power, Yeah. to have girls woman. Yeah.
That so Muhammad was nothing different
than us. We are the same
just To have what?
>> nothing different. The only was maybe he
was a good speaker. He wasn't a good
speaker. Brother, where did he lie? Huh?
He never lied Alaihi Wasallam when he
was alive. What did he say? He said al
kadhib lying leads to evil. And evil
leads to the hellfire. Even his enemies,
do you know they used to call him
as-sadiqul amin, the trustworthy and the
truthful one. His enemies, remember your
enemies they will look for anything to
accuse you of things. But guess what? If
his enemies called him the truthful and
honest,
Subhanallah.
But and what we say to you, Prophet
Muhammad Alaihi Wasallam, to show you
that that this man was a truthful
person,
Prophet Muhammad Alaihi Wasallam when
his son passed away Ibrahim, the same
day his son passed away, eclipse
happened. You know eclipse? Yeah.
Eclipse, yeah.
>> Eclipse, yeah. So his companions said
the reason there's eclipse because the
Prophet Muhammad son passed away Alaihi
Wasallam.
So
So so what happened?
If he was a liar, he would have said
what? He would have said yes, you see my
son passed away. Look what happened to
the sun and the moon. But what he said,
he said, "No.
Eclipse has nothing to do with no one's
life, no one's death." What he did
I will bring you the story. What he
said, he said, "When you see it, rush to
the prayer, pray to God." He never
connects the people to himself. To show
you Prophet Muhammad, he was an honest
person. Prophet Muhammad was a salam.
Prophet Muhammad was a salam.
He had a companion friend
that he was in love
No, no, there's who?
Who? I don't know what you mean.
No, there's many of them. Another
person. So, his friend he was in love
with a woman.
His wife. And his wife she wanted a
divorce.
So, Prophet Muhammad went to her and he
told her, "Why don't you go back to
him?" She said, "Oh, messenger of Allah,
do you want me to go back to him because
you're a messenger of Allah or you're
trying to mediate and help?"
Wait, step by step. That's his
companion. What this guy did to this
woman in it? No, no, he didn't mistreat
her. No, he gave her he gave her garden.
How he mistreat her?
Yeah, he gave her garden. Yes, for sure.
Okay, anyway.
I will show you the Hadith. Okay. Now,
the point here is Prophet Muhammad
if he was a liar, he would say to her,
"Yes, Allah told me go back to him." Cuz
a liar would would say anything. But
what he said, "Allah never told me
nothing about this. I'm trying to help,
but it's up to you." Look at the
characteristics of our beloved Prophet
Muhammad.
Compare Prophet Muhammad and Jesus. When
a man came to kill Prophet Muhammad was
a salam he never cried or he said or he
start begging. No. He said, "Yes, Allah
will help me."
Stand firm. But you have Jesus
Jesus was crying and and and and and and
getting beat up. I don't believe that by
the way. But Jesus I don't want to
compare between the two because both of
them are our prophets and messengers.
No, no, this afterwards was added by
John.
This is the only plan that can be can be
saved. So if you
That's contradiction. That's
contradiction. That's contradiction.
That's Why is contradiction? If Jesus
came to lay out lay down himself, why
was he begging God to save him?
It say it say doesn't make any sense.
He was He was obedient
to death for us. By the way, he doesn't
believe he's God. He doesn't believe
Jesus is He is God. Yeah, yeah, yeah. He
doesn't believe.
No, but he doesn't believe same thing.
Okay. So what I'm saying doesn't make
any sense. That Imagine I said, "I'M
COMING TO DIE FOR YOU. THAT'S WHAT I'M
COMING FOR." THEN WE SAW SOMEONE TRY TO
KILL ME FOR YOU ON THE WAY. THEN YOU
HANG ON. You just told me you come to
die for me. Why you run away? WHY YOU
SCARED?
CUZ WHY? YOU KNOW WHAT THEY SAY I'M
SORRY I'M SORRY. YOU KNOW WHAT they say?
In in ease everyone CAN SPEAK, BUT IN
THE HARDSHIP THAT'S WHEN you see real
man, you know?
But you see the thing is we we can't We
can't see through the Bible. We know
that Jesus Christ allow us of many
things.
Like uh you guys using
Hadith, yeah. But we we have the gospel.
The gospel is show every area in our
life. No, it doesn't. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, tell me what It doesn't because it
doesn't. Tell me about his childhood.
How he spent his childhood.
It's not in the Bible.
>> Okay, but the childhood only show Tell
me how he slept. TELL ME HOW JESUS
SLEPT.
SORRY. TELL ME HOW JESUS SLEPT. As a
12-year-old Tell me how Jesus slept.
What is that Is that what you are
talking about? Tell me how he enter his
house. The only person Sorry, sorry,
sorry. The only person The only person
that we know about him everything how he
enter his house, how he came out, how he
slept is the Prophet Muhammad
And that shows you what What shows you?
His companions, they were very What do
they call it?
Very that
they were very motivated to TEACH US
ABOUT SMALL THINGS. So it's more
logically they will preserve the major
teaching. You understand?
>> all vain things because it's not
important. Important is
your heart
how you how you
>> And your actions as well. Your actions
and your words.
Yeah, your actions, your heart.
And
And also your faith.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, go on then.
It's your heart and your actions.
>> Yeah,
and actions, yeah. Yeah, but it's
important as well. So why Islam Islam is
a way of life. That's the beauty of
Islam. Islam Allah knows how to sleep.
That's why doctors tell you the best way
to sleep on your right hand side.
And what Prophet Muhammad I don't
I think it's superstition. It's not
superstition.
>> Brother, I used to be Catholic. I know
what it is. It's not superstition. But
doctors will say to you
brother, scientifically proven,
scientifically proven, sleeping on the
right hand side is much better when you
sleep on your left cuz you put pressure
on your heart. Brother, look, you say
you put too much pressure on the people.
Important is
>> Why do I put pressure on people? If you
lying, stealing,
you're fornicating, those things are
important.
>> No, what I'm saying so it's not
important about me. So so it's not
>> [laughter]
>> health is not important. Sorry? Your
health is not important.
>> Of course it is. That's it. So it's
important. Prophet Muhammad alayhis
salat was salam, that's why Islam Allah
cuz why? Islam it comes teach about you
physical thing, YOU SPIRITUAL THING, YOU
BIOLOGICAL THING TO SHOW YOU ISLAM from
the creator who create everything.
You see? IT'S LIKE IF YOU MAKE A CAR, if
you make a car, you going to give a
detail about the car. The menu that
you're going to have explains everything
about the car.
>> the Bible, brother. No, the Bible
doesn't explain it.
No, it doesn't. It doesn't. In the
beginning you see the creation. OKAY,
TELL ME HOW TELL ME HOW TO
JESUS NEVER HAD CHILDREN, never had a
wife. So we don't know how to deal with
a wife.
SO JESUS NEVER HAD A WIFE.
NO, what I'm saying, Prophet Muhammad
alayhis salat was salam had a wife cuz
many people claim to be good men Yeah.
but when they get married they get
exposed by their wives. They were evil.
You understand? You know what I'm
saying? You know what I'm saying? Let me
out and I understand. Let me understand.
Let me understand. Try to understand my
point, yes? So Prophet Muhammad
we can see his wives loved him. You see
now look at this man, his mother hates
him. OKAY? IMAGINE ALL MOTHERS HATE YOU.
THAT'S BAD. YOU LIKE
NO, YOU DON'T BELIEVE JESUS TO BE GOD?
You don't believe Jesus to be God?
Yeah. Of course. Yeah, he believes Jesus
to be God. Debate each other. Come
record them. Debate each other. Debate
him. He believes Jesus to be God.
All right, TAKE CARE OF YOURSELF. What I
was talking to you. All right, take
care. Bye-bye. That's it. Now debate
each other. Jesus to be God.